I like to start speaking when I have
about 3,000 known words in a language
this is what I'm finding right now some
people may start to speak earlier some
people may want to delay it it depends
on your personality it depends on the
language you're learning how different
it is from languages that you already
know how much common vocabulary there is
and so forth but eventually you should
speak you should schedule with one of
our tutors or if we don't have a tutor
in that language you can use one of the
other communities online such as I
talked ii which offer native speaker
tutors whether you're with a link tutor
or someone at itok ii make sure you get
a rapport with the words and phrases at
least some of them the words and phrases
that you had difficulty with so that
this report can be imported into link
and that you can study it and hopefully
eventually improve but it takes a long
time to get to a level of fluency so
make sure you're patient but do force
yourself at some point to start speaking